hey guys my name is Jess McDowell and we
are back bringing you the news from
Australia in the early hours of the
morning here's a bunch of things that
happened while you're awake and LU
sleeping as you know that a portable
steam machine exists it's called smash 0
and its release window and price dropped
today previously called the steam boy
you can pick up this now ludicrously
named device when it comes out in the
fourth quarter of this year and it'll
cost you two hundred and ninety-nine
bucks it has 4 gigabytes of RAM a 720p
touchscreen hdmi output Bluetooth and
Wi-Fi connectivity a configurable
gamepad and 32 gigabytes of space as a
steam machine it runs valve steam OS so
will presumably let you access your less
demanding steam games on the go next up
a lot of us have been holding out for
the next entry in the Elder Scrolls
series but unfortunately Bethesda of
said all their attention is on fallout 4
even though Skyrim shifted 20 million
copies as de marketing executive Pete
Hines told Jill Shockers that the
company's next project is a long way off
pine said it would be a very long time
before the studio begins discussing
what's coming up after fallout 4 that
said Bethesda did disclose that they've
been working on fallout 4 ever since
fallout 3 wrapped up so you never know
in the meantime Bethesda has announced
they're working on the Elder Scrolls
legend which is looking like a half
stone esque free-to-play card game not
the Elder Scrolls game you want but it's
the one you're getting and finally needs
the speeds about the ghost games will
come out to defend a choice to make the
upcoming racer always online executive
producer Marcus Nilsson told official
Xbox Magazine that the always-online
functionality is there to support a
number of features including the
evolution of social platform auto log he
explains this time around we're going to
give it more of a human voice it will
treat your friends play as if it's part
of the narrative experience nelson says
the constant connection
also helps facilitate the snapshot
system where you can take photos have
people like them on the need for speed
network and get in-game currency as a
reward in comparison Ubisoft's
open-world racer the crew is also an
always-online game and ran into some
trouble and criticisms at launch because
of it need for speed is launching for pc
ps4 and xbox one on november 3 let me
know down in that comment box where you
think of need for speed being always
online you can have the game spot for
our Dark Souls 3 interview with head
Atacama is dark and our review that
everybody's gone to the rupture that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
today as always let me know what
mattered to you and I'll have a bunch
more news for you same time tomorrow